well we already have water refugees in
the world thousands and thousands of
them people who are seeking water and so
moving from where they've run out of
water or they've created deserts to
places where there there is water
already there are 2 billion people
living in parts of the world that don't
have enough water and oh well over 1
billion who have absolutely no access to
clean water at all so they die I mean
basically you know when you have no you
can't afford water because they're
pricing in you go to the rivers that
have cholera warning signs on them and
that's the water you use and you watch
your kids die a horrible death more
children die in our water our world of
waterborne disease every day then
hiv/aids war traffic accidents and
malaria put together it's the number one
killer of kids and it's absolutely
totally preventable half the hospital
beds in the world half the hospital bits
in the world are filled with people who
would not be there if they had access to
clean water it you know it's I i call it
the inconvenient truth about water
because I think that the way that
consciousness about greenhouse gas
emissions and climate change has now
suddenly begun to permeate everybody's
mind I think similarly this issue around
waters got to get to that level where
it's just really fundamental for people
but living without water is a crisis and
then if you're in a wealthier country
like Australia that's running out of
water people aren't dying and that's
absolutely true but there is now a whole
new frantic feeling about water and
people telling on each other if they
water the lawns at night because they're
not supposed to mean there now on boil
water alert sore there on really really
strict water diets in the beach in the
major cities because you know the Sydney
has maybe three to five maybe ten years
of water conventional water sources left
so they're building these great big
desalination plants which are expensive
and energy intensive and produce a very
highly polluting brine that you put back
out into the ocean and in my opinion is
what
you do when you run out of every other
option right but I mean instead of
thinking about real serious conservation
and understanding that we have to change
our ways and we have to protect source
water we're still in denial and and
people need to understand that the the
Atlanta story is a story you're going to
hear more and more and more about even
here in North America where we've had
this myth of abundance of water